when I was growing up I spend a lot of
time outside never going these
adventures either in the local park or
even my front yard
and I spent a lot of time searching for
four-leaf clovers
[Music]
science starts with observation being
able to play close attention and ask
questions that's the spark of science
[Music]
oh wait a minute here's another there's
usually a good sign I like to put traps
where I see a lot of 40 clovers I'm
Danielle in Lee I'm a National
Geographic emerging Explorer and I study
nuisance rates a nuisance or pest animal
is any animal that gives people a
problem roams like rats and mice have
been a problem for humans since the
beginning of time they can cause a lot
of disease so we want to understand more
about them so that we can live healthier
better lives I'm interested in studying
nuisance rodents because I want to
understand how these animals
successfully persist despite how hard
people have tried to get rid of them for
hundreds of years so I studied feel mice
across an urban to rural gradient so
that's looking from a big city all the
way to a farm area to a more natural
area where there's more forests and
grasslands I'm trying to understand the
behavioral differences of city mice and
country mice
I like these small traps because they
carry well in your bag I'll open them up
and they're ready to go and then when I
find the perfect place where I think
Mike's maybe it's just as easy as that
to set them come back just a couple
hours later and I can't catch a mouse if
they're out here this is the urban part
of my gradient here in the st. Louis
metro area here surrounded by buildings
there's still a lot of places for
wildlife like nuisance rodents to find a
perfect place to live and make a living
[Music]
[Laughter]
once we've captured them I safely remove
them from the trap he swatted like a
baby definitely a male 14-point way them
different parts of their body
and then we individually identify them
with attack this gives us a glimpse into
how animal communities are using
habitats in our area understanding what
makes city mouse and country mouse the
same and different from one another is
the goal of my research and I'm
interested in differences that might
make them bolder and risk coming into
your house as opposed to staying outside
I think understanding them better is how
we do better at living around them so
release our back to where she came from
and if I catch her again in the same
place then I know that this is roughly
what she's made of home I think it's
important too to do science close to
home there's so many questions that we
still don't know and so many answers
that we've yet to find about the
wildlife that lives right outside of our
door there are living laboratories all
around us and you can get started now
they're shipping
[Music]
you